off the final liftoff of Atlantis on the
shoulders of the space July the 11th
2011. the last space shuttle launch in
the beginning of what many commentators
call America's decade-long Space Program
slump
the Kennedy Space Center laid off more
than 7 000 workers and space enthusiasts
who filled restaurants and hotels and
lined ashore to watch launches
disappeared
but NASA's reinvigorated Space Program
and a boost from private companies like
SpaceX and Blue Horizon means Florida's
so-called Space Coast is alive again
I'm just happy it's booming the way it
is I'm happy they got the program going
back up now I'm happy people can come
out and enjoy it with us so I think it's
cool
several rocket launchers are carried out
each month including SpaceX carrying
starlink internet satellites more than
12 000 civil servants private
contractors and others now work at the
Kennedy Space Center almost as many as
those employed during the Heyday of the
shuttle program on a mission to prepare
for the next era of world cooperation in
space
hotels and restaurants are filling up
once more
it excites me that the people are still
excited enough in in this country to
flow here to see it they still look at
it as historic and I hope we never lose
that
um you know it's obviously good for the
space program it's good for the country
and it's certainly good for the city of
Titusville and Brevard County you know
we're back you know and it's the kind of
the saying goes now we're going
to the Moon NASA says it's set to launch
the Artemis moon mission on Saturday
after problems with an engine cooling
system delayed liftoff last week Space
Coast Spectators will be again packed
along these Florida shores
Charles Stratford and Jazeera